ratios are comparisons between the same
kind of quantity and rates are
comparisons between different quantities
what was the example I remember I gave
you a puzzle this morning
what was the comparison between rosio
kilometers per hour
that's distance and time so that's why
you get this is the idea in the world
okay so what I'm going to give you is
three overarching tips that were helping
with all the right problems that you
deal with and we're gonna have some
examples together okay so firstly
because we just said the whole idea is
that the rates are different quantities
the most important thing in the question
is to identify the users because the
unit's tell you what kind of quantities
you're dealing with kilometers and
meters and centimeters they're all
distances hours and minutes seconds
they're all time you need to look at
that really carefully and if you're in a
test I would like right on the test
I'd like undle I can see units will
highlight or whatever you choose so
first step identify the guiness secondly
breathe the question carefully and then
choose whether you're going to take the
quantities in the question and multiply
them so choose multiplication or
sometimes you need to divide now the
example we looked at this morning now is
60 kilometers per hour and I said how
long would it take I think the number
was 210 kilometers do you remember that
yeah now you can see I've got two times
here 60 210 and I can multiply them or I
can divide them right 60 times 210 I
could done what that is it's very large
no but that's something like that okay
really big number multiply them doesn't
give me the answer to this doesn't give
me the time I had to divide remember
that and so choosing once again from
division that's a really important step
you have to think before you put your
pen to paper okay last general tip
because the units are so important you
really should
include them include units when you're
actually setting out your question in
your working okay so for example in this
case here we worked at it was division
in this case if you want to know the
total time I wouldn't just write 210
divided by 60 vote even though that
would give me the right number which I
think was it three and a half three
point five instead of writing this I
would prefer to write 210 kilometers
divided by 60 kilometers per hour
include the unit's in there I know
sometimes and I'm good to these
sometimes as well
I like just write the numbers and I'll
do all my calculations and then at the
very end I'll white put the unit's in
right but I think that's a bad idea
students have to get confused when they
do that well they just forget entirely
okay so here are my three tips identify
choose and include I uh sure open up -
1206 now we're gonna do the first two
questions to get on and one that's later
in the exercise - um you may like to
stay key because we're gonna keep on
doing stuff yeah good good
okay so we start with a really simple
one but I've left the clues for tips on
the board so that we can use them as we
go okay so have a look at number one
with me
let's read it it says Ben types
fifty-five words per minute how many
words can you type in 20 minutes okay
that's all there is to the question
let's go through one at a time first I'm
trying to identify the units what are
these just just tell me
yep Oh interesting
the 55 and 20 they do really matter to
me but they're actually the quantities
the numbers the units are gonna be like
is it a distance is it a time in this
case its I got a time what's the time
unit use it have a look at the question
is a time unit and its minutes very good
what's the other it's a rate so I have
to have more than one unit what's the
other one what right in fact one of the
big clues before doing this for
identifying the units is look for that
word right well we see this a lot right
something per something means these two
quantities are connected together okay
so i've identified words minutes choose
now have a look at the numbers on an
already mentioned 55 and 20 may be
important numbers what am I gonna do
with these numbers do i multiply or do i
divide just pause for a second before
you goodnight son you want to know how
many words you can type in total okay
sorry I saw your head not what do you
think okay I think it's multiplication
to know let's just have a go of this
because one of the great things we can
do is check if we get something
reasonable okay so now I'm gonna do the
last thing I'm gonna include the units
in my working I've got 55 words and then
we often use a slash
like that to indicate per minute right
so I'm including the units in this line
of working I'm about to write it was
suggested to use multiplication so I'm
gonna go times 20 and this is 20 minutes
isn't it 20 it's ok there yeah so I've
got the right numbers I've included the
unit's in there and now I'm gonna
actually start to work this out now
remember I said this is a substitute you
may want to put an arrow to that and say
that but this is a substitute for the
word okay it's also at the same time a
substitute for a on a fraction line okay
so we can write this in another way that
I'm gonna encourage all of you to do
it's like we've got 50 were 55 words
rather as a numerator and one bitter as
the denominator this is the same thing
55 words per minute multiplied by now
the lovely thing about writing it like
this is that can you see have a look at
my unit really carefully do you see I've
got minutes on the bottom over here and
minutes at the top over here right well
what you've got the same thing on the
top and the bottom of a fraction what
can you do with it if I if I had
something like 3 out of 6 I can see
there's a 3 here and a 3 here what can I
do to this fraction I can use anymore
I could simplify by canceling right I
can divide this by 3 which gives me 1
and I can divide this by 3 which gives
me cool so that's huff I can do exactly
the same thing here minutes minutes they
cancelled ok so one of the lovely things
about this is if you've written your
unit in there this tells us
multiplication was the right thing to do
cuz what's the question again look
carefully it says how many words and
words is the unit's left behind okay
ideally his left is just to crunch the
numbers 55 times 20
when we do this together I fifty times
fifty five times two is a hundred and
ten isn't it and then I'm gonna bring
the zero back so that's one thousand one
hundred what are you happy with that do
you see the way I thought about it and
how I I incorporated all of these
approaches you can see as well how I got
it wrong right had I actually thought oh
maybe it's division maybe I should go
like fifty five words per minute and
maybe I'll try dividing by 20 20 right
it doesn't it's not that unusual to take
a big number divided by small number you
see it's not gonna work right the units
aren't going to cancel the way they did
before this minutes is gonna be down
here you're going to get minutes squared
whatever that means so you can see
including units helps you get the
operation right